let's go to the phones a lot of people  at home wanna say their piece and we  welcome that the phone number is 6 1 7 8  3 0 47 50 let's go - lets go - Tyler  from the 6 5 0 we haven't heard from  Tyler in twenty twenty what's going on  Tyler hey David how's it going can you  hear me yes I can  hey I was just calling in just to see  how you were doing during this  quarantine time and also I had a quick  question about Joe Biden sure yeah I  mean listen I I rec it's I don't love  the quarantine I'm bored  blah-blah-blah-blah-blah you know it's  more that it's more claustrophobia than  boredom but I recognize that I've not  lost my job I have food to eat you know  I recognize that I do not have it  anywhere near as bad as millions and  millions of people do and I'm just  taking it a day at a time basically  Tyler all right well  Tyler's gone would have loved to have  heard that Joe Biden question but anyway  at least I got that first part first  part out there for you guys